momento de hablar de salud y ya nos
acompaña en el estudio mar Romero sala
bienvenida Gracias Rosa bienvenida tú
también mar y nos trae hoy un tema que
tiene muchísimas aristas entre ellas la
lista de la salud No cómo va a afectar
que el Ártico se quede totalmente sin
hielo algo que podría pasar en los
próximos 20 años sí por primera vez
además no ha pasado nunca antes y es una
de las conclusiones publicadas por un
estudio muy exhaustivo publicado ayer en
la revista en hechos vamos primero a
revisar los datos Y luego las
consecuencias básicamente predice que el
Ártico se podría quedar sin hielo
completamente en septiembre que
correspondería digamos al final del
verano en el hemisferio norte por
primera vez entre 2030 y 2050 y que
además de eso pasaría Incluso en los
escenarios más optimistas de
calentamiento global que no supere los
dos grados centígrados es decir que es
prácticamente Inevitable que eso suceda
el Ártico podría quedarse totalmente sin
hielo al final del verano en el Hemi
Norte No en el mes de septiembre
aproximadamente sí y que eso es la
primera vez además que puede suceder y
que pasaría Incluso como decíamos en los
escenarios más optimistas de
calentamiento global es decir que no
superemos a los dos grados centígrados
de calentamiento eso además también
predice que si no se reducen las
emisiones en 2100 es decir en los
próximos 80 años podríamos llegar a que
el Ártico estuviera sin hielo durante
medio año y también cuantifica el
estudio Los motivos del deshielo que eso
es muy interesante porque hay varios
impactos que pueden hacer que pueden
tener una un efecto sobre el hielo del
Ártico no pero básicamente concluyen que
la actividad humana y el calentamiento
global los gases invernaderos emitidos
por culpa de la actividad humana son
responsables en un 90% de este deshielo
del Ártico vamos a revisar una imagen
del estudio que lo que hace es recoger
recordemos datos satelitales desde 1979
hasta 2019 40 años de información en
azul vemos cuando la masa de hielo
Ártico crece en rojo cuando la masa
ártica decrece lo que era habitual era
que Durante los meses fríos creciera la
masa de hielo Durante los meses cálidos
decreciera pero vemos que a partir de
finales del año 90 de la década de los
e incluso en los meses fríos es decir
Incluso en los meses de invierno No por
ejemplo vemos aquí enero febrero no
marzo está también en rojo es decir que
está perdiendo hielo Incluso en los
meses que debería estar considerandose
los meses fríos mar y qué preocupación
realmente que este sea el panorama en el
mejor de los escenarios no en los más
optimistas respecto a las consecuencias
de la crisis climática le pregunto
precisamente Qué impacto se espera que
tenga este futuro bastante inmediato
para nuestra salud pues son tantas que
es difícil contar vamos a primero
escuchar unas conclusiones del estudio
esto afectaría a la sociedad humana y al
ecosistema tanto dentro como fuera del
Ártico al cambiar las actividades
marinas del Polo Norte a la vez que
acelerar el calentamiento del Ártico y
alterar su ciclo de carbono entonces
sabemos que esto provoca cambios de
ecosistema no y que afectarán el globo
entero por supuesto todos los animales
ecosistemas alrededor del Ártico y por
lo tanto también las comunidades humanas
que viven alrededor de esos ecosistemas
se verán afectados pero es que incluso
océanos lejos del Ártico también se
pueden ver afectados estamos hablando de
que no haya hielo en el Ártico provoca
por ejemplo un desequilibrio por
explicarlo rápido del oxígeno en el agua
en el océano Y eso hace que haya plantas
y animales que viven a más de 2.000
metros de profundidad por ejemplo que no
que se puede hacer que no tengan acceso
a oxígeno también desequilibrando por lo
tanto ecosistemas mucho más allá del
ecosistema del Ártico también hay algo y
es que el deshielo puede acelerar el
propio calentamiento global Porque esa
de hielo refleja mucha radiación y mucho
calor solar Entonces no tener hielo
también favorece que aumente todavía más
la temperatura y sobre la salud se han
encontrado por ejemplo bacterias virus
de hace decenas de miles de años
congelados en el hielo del Ártico y en
las regiones de permafrost pues
alrededor de esa región ártica y que
podría ser entonces que la próxima
pandemia si coinciden muchos factores no
venga de los animales de las selvas
tropicales sino más bien de este hielo
que se deshace no y por supuesto hasta
las consecuencias geopolíticas de abrir
una nueva ruta de comercio incluso a
través a través del Ártico realmente son
incalculables sí totalmente
incalculables muchas consecuencias que
seguro ni imaginamos en estos en estos
momentos le propongo que cambiemos de
tema porque también ha habido una
revelación sobre los impactos que podría
tener la contaminación dentro de
nuestros propios hogares No sí se
publicó ayer un informe sobre el acceso
a la energía sostenible en el mundo y
nos vamos a centrar en de los datos
quedan la OMS en este caso que es del
acceso a las energías limpias para
cocinar cuando hablamos de polución nos
imaginamos las calles nos imaginamos las
fábricas pero no nos imaginamos nuestras
propias cocinas Y es que tiene fuertes
impactos que un cuarto de la población
mundial cocine con fuentes de energía
como el carbón como la madera o como el
queroseno y además un impacto que suele
ser desigual en el caso de las mujeres
que están más cerca digamos de los
fogones en términos de cifras no es
menor son 3,2 millones de muertes
anuales atribuibles a esta contaminación
la mitad de estas muertes son por
enfermedades cardiovasculares el 40% por
enfermedades pulmonares y el 6% por
cáncer de pulmón y por supuesto también
en este caso los niños son una población
especialmente vulnerable 240.000 muertes
anuales en menores de 5 años por
pulmonías a raíz de esta contaminación
doméstica que empieza en la cocina sí
que poco pensamos en esta en esta
situación lumar y le preguntó Cuál es
precisamente el escenario en el
continente americano sí quizás pensamos
poco en esto porque nosotras estamos muy
acostumbradas a cocinar con las estufas
de gas normales que no sienten tantos a
contaminación Pero no es así en todo el
mundo Aquí vemos el mapa de la región
americana y vemos que por ejemplo en los
países con más recursos se llega hasta
un 100% de la población con acceso a
energías limpias estamos hablando de
Estados Unidos Canadá también a chile y
Argentina en el cono Sur pero vemos Que
hay muchos países con situaciones más
preocupantes por ejemplo Guatemala
Honduras no llegan a la mitad de la
población cocinando de una forma digamos
saludable en este sentido de la energía
y Haití ni siquiera llega el 25% al
final no este mapa como un reflejo más
de las de los impactos que tienen las
desigualdades sobre la salud de las
personas no Y cómo tener acceso a una
buena cocina o no tiene consecuencias
insospechadas sobre sobre nuestra salud
completamente más Muchísimas gracias por
hacernos ver precisamente estas
consecuencias la esperamos mañana aquí
en directamente Hasta mañana Rosa
[Música]